ja meine damen und herren christian
lindner und ich haben gestern mit
annalena baerbock und robert habeck ein
erstes vertrauliches gespräch geführt
und sind überein gekommen dass wir die
bilateralen gespräche in einer größeren
runde fortsetzen wollen dazu werden sich
bündnis 90 die grünen und die freien
demokraten am kommenden freitag treffen
dabei sollen erste inhaltliche fragen
vertieft werden
die unionsparteien haben die freien
demokraten zu einem gespräch eingeladen
dieses gesprächsangebot haben die freien
demokraten heute angenommen unser
angebot ist das gespräch am kommenden
samstag zu führen die union prüft das
noch
wie bereits öffentlich angekündigt haben
auch die sozialdemokraten uns gespräche
angeboten auch dieses gesprächsangebot
nehmen wir selbstverständlich an wir
haben vereinbart unsere kommenden
sonntag zu einem bilateralen austausch
zu treffen nach diesen gesprächen werden
wir unsere gremien darüber unterrichten
und sodann über den weiteren verlauf
beratung
kommen dann zu den fragen die erste
frage bitte von herrn leithäuser
wenn sie sagen sie treffen sich in
größerer runde am freitag können sie
beschreiben wie groß diese runde sein
wird von ihrer seite oder fanseiten
würde es wird ja sicher paritätisch
besetzt sein und welche inhaltlichen
fragen wenn sie das stichwort ich es
gesehen könnten haben sie identifiziert
über die jetzt vertiefen der
gesprächsbedarf besteht
die fdp wird mit den mitgliedern des
präsidiums an dieser fan schon an diesen
gesprächen teilnehmen und die
inhaltlichen fragen sind die die ihnen
bekannten fragen die auch im wahlkampf
eine zentrale rolle gespielt haben so
dass wir jetzt die dinge die wir
wahlkampf stark kommuniziert haben auch
auch
im hinblick auf eine mögliche
zusammenarbeit miteinander
prüfen und abklärung
herausgebers bitte
vielen dank herr wissing es gab
eigentlich dem plan dass sie sich heute
zu gesprächen treffen gab es ein grund
dafür dass man das auf gestern abend
vorverlegt hat wir haben über diese
gespräche nichts kommuniziert und haben
die gespräche so durchgeführt wir sie
geplant
bitteschön
ja vielleicht später von rtl n-tv grüße
sie herr wissing in dem social media
post von gestern abend hieß es man hätte
auch gemeinsamkeiten identifiziert
welche sind das dann können sie das mal
erklären wir haben über die gespräche
vertraulichkeit vereinbart uns ist es
besonders wichtig dass die gespräche in
einem geschützten vertraulichen rahmen
stattfinden können es ist sind wichtige
fragen die dort erörtert werden müssen
und deswegen bleibt es dabei dass ich
über die inhalte ihnen heute nicht sagen
können er will lieber bitte
wie wahr welt sie sprachen davon sie
haben wollen die inhaltlichen fragen
vertiefen das heißt also mit anderen
worten sie haben ja über inhalte dann
auch schon gesprochen und nicht nur über
das prozedere können sie denn sagen
welche themen da zumindest mal
angesprochen worden sind und zu den
künftigen gesprächen will werden wir
davon was mitbekommen dass sie sich
treppen oder ist wieder geplant gegessen
haben und das dann irgendwie die selbst
später darum geschickt werden oder wird
es daher ganz offiziell die dann dazu
eingeladen so dass man halt auch davon
etwas mitbekommt im zweifel
wir haben alle
erfahrungen mit sondierungsgesprächen
und vor sondierungen und wir haben
daraus auch die notwendigen schlüsse
gezogen und es ist das besonders wichtig
dass die ersten gespräche in einem
vertrauensvollen und vertraulichen
rahmen geführt werden können das haben
wir gemeinsam sichergestellt und
deswegen kann ich ihnen über die inhalte
dieses gesprächs nichts berichten
wir haben uns dann aber entschieden weil
wir wissen dass es natürlich auch ein
großes öffentliches interesse daran gibt
dass wir ein bild sprechen lassen das
haben wir getan will aber auch dieses
bild jetzt nicht mit worten
interpretieren um die vertraulichkeit
der gespräche zu schützen
letztendlich werden wir in zukunft wenn
wir zu entscheidungen kommen diese auch
öffentlich machen und werden diese
entscheidung dann auch inhaltlich
begründen
nicht klar ob sie am freitag dann das in
ähnlicher art und weise organisieren im
geheimen organisieren werden und am
samstag und am sonntag ob das jetzt so
intendiert ist dass sie also tatsächlich
hat unter ausschluss der öffentlichkeit
ohne bekanntgabe von terminen und
örtlichkeiten dann sich zusammensetzen
oder ob sie tatsächlich dann auch das
anders kommunizieren als es gestern arm
des geschehens wir bereiten das gespräch
am freitag gegenwärtig vor und werden in
den nächsten tagen aufklären oder
kurzfristig klären wie wir das
öffentlich kommunizieren und
selbstverständlich wollen wir die
öffentlichkeit
nach möglichkeit beteiligen aber das
geht eben nur in dem rahmen in dem dinge
nicht vertraulich sein müssen
dann kommen wir zu herrn hofmann bitte
wir sehen wenn sie sagen wir meinen sie
sicherlich die fdp das heißt sie fühlen
die gespräche mit union und spd
getrennt von den grünen oder führen sie
die zusammen erste frage und zweite
frage in dem zusammenhang er gibt es
einen grund für die reihenfolge oder wie
ist es dazu gekommen erst union dann spd
ja wir führen diese gespräche getrennt
weil wir das für erforderlich halten
dass wir zunächst einmal immer ihren
bilateralen miteinander brechen es muss
ja am ende wenn man zu einem bündnis
kommt jeder mit jedem zusammenarbeiten
wollen deswegen ist das in bilateralen
gesprächen zunächst einmal vorab zu
klären und die
reihenfolge
ergibt sich aus der situation wie die
terminlage sich darstellt es ist
natürlich jetzt nicht ganz einfach also
viele gespräche mit vielen personen in
kurzer zeit zu terminieren wir sind zu
dieser reihenfolge entsprechend gekommen
herr schuld bitte die nächste frage
wir sind als sünder hat gestern ein
schulz zum wahlsieg gratuliert und
gesagt der regierungsauftrag liegt klar
bei der spd sehen sie das auch so und
wenn ja wann gratulieren sie seien stolz
zu sein
wir haben selbstverständlich
wahrgenommen dass die spd besser
abgeschnitten ist bei dieser
bundestagswahl als die union und wie
sich das unter demokraten gehört haben
wir uns auch am wie rocky herrn scholz
auch gratuliert das gehört sich so ich
habe persönlich habe das gemacht hat an
der persönlichen begegnung
am rande einer fernsehsendung
nachfrage
weil bislang vonseiten fdp nicht gegeben
selbstverständlich haben wir gesehen
dass die spd das beste wahlergebnis
erzielt hat und selbstverständlich
erkennen wir dieses wahlergebnisses an
herr brüssler bitte
ja ja wir sind hier ist sinn und
systematik der gespräch jetzt noch nicht
ganz klar geworden die gespräche am
samstag und sonntag mit union und spd
das ziel dieser gespräche wollen sie
dann sehr schnell ausloten ob es
überhaupt sinn hat weiter zu verhandeln
und dann nur noch mit einer der beiden
seiten weiter verhandeln und vor so
einer entscheidung gebe es dann wieder
eine rückkopplung mit den grünen oder
wie soll das funktionieren
zunächst einmal ist es wichtig dass wenn
parteien miteinander eine
regierungsverantwortung übernehmen
wollen dass sie klären ob sie
miteinander zusammenarbeiten wollen das
muss man an vielerlei dingen fest machen
und klären kann man das nur in
bilateralen gesprächen die müssen jetzt
stattfinden und sind dieser gespräche
ist genau diese frage zu klären
natürlich muss auch über
inhaltliche fragen gesprochen werden
vertieft kann man das richtig tief kann
man das allerdings nur in
koalitionsverhandlungen machen und in
welcher konstellation es dazu kommt da
kann ich heute nicht zu sagen das ist zu
früh sonst würden wir diese gespräche ja
nicht was machen terminieren wenn wir
deren ergebnis heute schon antizipieren
könnten
herting bitte die nächste frage
wissing wenn sie sagen am wochenende war
die gespräche führen mit union und auch
der spd gehen sie da dann mit einem ich
sag mal forderungskatalog mit einem
grundlagenpapier mit mit ersten ideen
die sie dann skizziert habe
möglicherweise auch in den gesprächen
mit den grünen in diese ersten gespräche
hinein so dass das eine vollkommen
offene kommunikation wie geht das
wir haben uns sehr intensiv mit dem mit
den wahlprogrammen auseinandergesetzt
natürlich besonders mit dem eigenen aber
auch mit dem programm der
mitbewerberinnen und mitbewerber
und jetzt müssen wir darüber sprechen
wie man sich vorstellt im falle einer
zusammenarbeit die dinge zu ordnen
formal müssen parteien unterschiedliche
programme machen und wenn es zum
koalitionsregierung kann müssen sie nach
wahlen ausloten wo eine zusammenarbeit
möglich ist und ob diese möglichkeit der
zusammenarbeit sich in den themenfeldern
ergibt die den partnern besonders
wichtig sind und das ist die arbeit die
jetzt für uns im zentrum steht da wird
muss es gespräche geben die in
vertraulicher atmosphäre stattfinden und
es wird natürlich auch öffentliche
erklärung dazu geben immer sobald wir
etwas zu erklären haben
nochmal der kollege rtl n-tv bitte
weswegen der stuhl in der union von
armin laschet scheint ja zu wackeln hat
dass irgendwelche auswirkungen auf die
gespräche mit der union am wochenende
und wie gehen sie damit um wenn armin
laschet möglicherweise nicht mehr
parteivorsitzender sein wird am
wochenende
das hat keine auswirkungen auf die
gespräche weil die gespräche für uns von
unserer seite sich nicht an der union
orientieren sondern in unserem
wahlprogramm das sich durch die
diskussionen innerhalb der union ja
nicht verändert und
über eventualitäten
die die sich ergeben könnten haben wir
uns keine gedanken gemacht wir
orientieren uns an dem was wir vor der
wahl gesagt haben an den inhaltlichen
positionen die sind für uns der
entscheidende maßstab
hinzu kommen muss aber natürlich auch
dass der wille zur zusammenarbeit
besteht und das ist eben das was man
ausloten muss und und in gesprächen
klären muss
für uns stehen die inhalte unserer
unseres programms im zentrum wir haben
wieder vor der wahl haben wir politik
für kandidaten anderer parteien gemacht
und genau so werden wir das auch nach
der wahl halten es kommt auf die
inhaltlichen fragen an es geht nicht um
personen sondern um die
inhalte der regierung da ist des
regierungsprogramms sie kommen zum
kollegen von der zeit hier am tisch wir
sind kurze frage halten sie eigentlich
die union angesichts des aktuellen
zustands für uneingeschränkt
regierungsfähig
ich blicke in die union nur in dem maße
finalen wie es öffentlich berichtet wird
ich nehme ja an den gremiensitzungen der
union nicht teil insofern haben wir hier
keine bewertung die wir abschließend
abgeben können und wir nehmen die
gesprächsangebote an und können die
dinge dann dort schwer
herr mainz bitte
wie lange und wo haben sie gestern
miteinander gesprochen und wo sind die
treffen am freitag samstag und runter
die die der ort und auch die art des
gespräches dass wir gestern geführt
haben ist vertraulich deswegen kann ich
ihnen dazu nichts sagen und
wir haben das gespräch insgesamt unter
verdaulichkeit gestellt weil wir das in
einer absolut geschützten atmosphäre
führen wollten das ist uns wichtig und
deswegen bleibt es dabei dass ich ihn
wieder zur dauer noch zum ort dieses
gespräches oder auch der
gesprächsatmosphäre irgend eine
andeutung machen kann aber
die zweite frage die wird im moment noch
geklärt das sind rein organisatorische
gründe wir werden das an einem
geeigneten ort durchführen
und werden das pragmatisch entscheiden
die kollegen in der ersten
reporter von bild hallo sie haben ja
vorher die ganze zeit also als fdp
gesagt dass sie am liebsten eine
jamaika-koalition gründen würden würden
sie dir diese koalitionspräferenzen
jetzt immer noch bestätigen wir haben
das ja inhaltlich begründet und nachdem
sich an den inhalten mit denen die
parteien sich präsentiert haben nichts
geändert hat haben wir
selbstverständlich auch diese
präferenz weiterhin die letzte frage
bitte 23
alexander rath von reuters daran
anknüpfend angesichts der politischen
stimmung im land und auch der äußerungen
die von den grünen kommen für wie
realistisch halten sie den jamaika jetzt
noch
wenn ich das wüsste bräuchten wir die
gespräche ja nicht zu führen die wir
jetzt vorhaben und weil wir diese
gespräche mit ernsthaftigkeit und auch
mit offenheit führen kann ich ihnen
diese frage beim besten willen nicht
beantworten vorher
gesagt sie wollten das bild sprechen
lassen was sollte das denn sagen das
bild dann noch eine weitere frage haben
sie ähnliche schweige vereinbarungen
oder vertraulichkeitsvereinbarungen
jetzt auch mit der spd und den unmut mit
und mit der spd und der union
und wer geht denn für sie zu den
gesprächen mit der spd und mit der union
das letzte habe ich akustisch nicht
verstanden
wir schicken sie als fdp zu den
gesprächen mit der union und spd
also zunächst einmal
ich habe ich ihn ja gesagt ich werde das
bild nicht mit worten interpretieren
sondern überlassen ihnen die
interpretation weil wir vertraulichkeit
vereinbart haben und in der stelle mit
dem bild einfach zeigen wollten wir
haben uns getroffen und haben
miteinander gesprochen alles andere
kann ich ihnen mitteilen dass wir die zu
den anderen die anderen gespräche das
werden wir mit den mit den jeweiligen
gesprächspartner erklären ich gehe davon
aus dass sie da zeitnah informiert
werden und in welcher konstellation wir
mit der union sprechen werden hängt
davon ab mit welcher konstellation die
union kommt wir haben uns im präsidium
der fdp darauf verständigt dass wir je
nachdem mit welcher zahl von personen
die der gesprächspartner mit uns
sprechen wollen eine bestimmte
bestimmten systematik innerhalb des
präsidiums wählen
herr polanski bitte
wie würden sie denn die atmosphäre im
augenblick zwischen spd und fdp
beschreiben wenn man bedenkt dass auch
diverse äußerungen hin und her gegangen
sind jetzt nochmal gestern frau
strack-zimmermann der gewinner nicht die
hellste kerze auf der torte bei auch
eine replik ein bisschen auf den kühler
hat also wie sehen sie die
voraussetzungen eigentlich atmosphärisch
für gespräche mit der spd offen gesagt
fehlt mir im augenblick die die zeit und
auch die aufmerksamkeit solche
äußerungen zu zu näher zu betrachten ich
halte sie nicht für relevant
wir kommen zur frage von herrn jahren
bitte deswegen nach dem gespräch gestern
was dann ihr eindruck sind die grünen
immer noch die verbots partei die sie im
wahlkampf erlebt und beschrieben haben
und wenn es um verhandlungsbereitschaft
geht ist denn die fdp verhandlungsbereit
beim thema schuldenbremse und
steuererhöhungen
das kann ich ihnen über die
verhandlungen kann ich ihnen nicht sagen
wann keine stattgefunden haben bisher
sondern nur ein gespräch und insofern
ist ja auch klar dass sich an den
programmen der parteien nichts geändert
hat und jetzt müssen wir in einem
gestuften verfahren vorgehen und klären
in welcher konstellation wir genau diese
fragen miteinander erörtern die sich
logischerweise stellen und diese auch zu
recht hier stellt haben aber ich kann
sie ihnen nicht zu beginn dieses
prozesses beantworten sondern erst zu
einem späteren zeitpunkt wenn wir diese
fragen mit den partnern vertieft
erörtern
das käme auch darauf an in welcher
konstellation die cdu/csu aufschlägt
dann am samstag wie sie sich dann
sozusagen
zusammenfinden mit der welt den personen
jetzt sagt ja wolfgang kubicki oder
glaubt ja nicht als armin laschet am
wochenende noch ein chart ist zumindest
hat er diesen eindruck erweckte glauben
sie dass auch oder rechnen sie damit das
sehe dann am samstag auch armin laschet
retten werden ich stelle mich auf die
situation ein die sich mir bietet das
ist die dinge verändert sich ja
erwartung erfahrungsgemäß immer sehr
kurzfristig im laufe einer einer solchen
phase nach der nach einer bundestagswahl
insofern ich kann mich nicht auf
eventualitäten einstellen die
möglicherweise oder möglicherweise auch
nicht eintreten sondern ich bereite
jetzt diese gespräche vor und warten
darauf welche personenanzahl die union
uns meldet und wir haben innerhalb des
präsidiums an eine sechser variante und
eine zehner variante festgelegt mit der
wir dann diese gespräche führen und sind
deswegen auf alle eventualitäten
vorbereitet und die internen
angelegenheiten der union glaube ich
kann sich selber besser beurteilen als
ich herr pressler bitte
nochmal versucht sind unseres thematik
der gespräche ist es auch ihr
verständnis dass jedes gespräch nur
solange sinn hat solange auch die andere
partei dieses gespräch führt also dass
sie mit und mit der union nicht weiter
zu reden brauchen in dem augenblick wo
die grünen sagen dass das gespräch keine
grundlage mehr hat und umgekehrt das ja
auch für die grünen gelten würde dass
sie nicht reden muss weiter wenn sie
sagen ampel hat für uns keine zukunft
ist das etwas worauf sie sich zwischen
den beiden parteien zumindest schon
verständigt haben dass es ohne innere
logik gibt
wenn das gespräch nicht vertraulich wäre
dann könnte ich ihnen diese frage
beantworten aber da es vertraulich ist
kann ich sie ihnen nicht beantworten
wir sind die das ziel der fdp ist dass
es zu einer regierungsbildung kommt und
nicht dass alle sich blockieren und eine
regierungsbildung erschweren das ist das
was ich ihnen dazu sagen kann und jetzt
gilt es mit allen erst einmal einer
gesprächsrunde durchzuführen um dann
sich ein gesamtbild zu machen und dann
werden wir den nächsten schritt gehen
wir kommen zur kollegin hier ganz links
aus
einer vom ndr
also ich hab das jetzt richtig
verstanden es gab eine einladung der spd
an fdp und gründe die nehmen sie in der
form nicht an sondern reden alleine mit
der spd ist die eine frage und die
andere frage ist seit wann haben sie
denn entschieden dass sie am sonntag mit
der spd reden
ja es ist richtig dass wir mit der spd
die lateral sprechen die das ist von
anfang an unser wunsch gewesen und die
einladung die die spd an uns
ausgesprochen hat habe ich oder frau hat
die fdp angenommen
wir haben diese das gesprächsangebot ist
ja sehr früh signalisiert worden seitens
der spd und wir haben von vornherein
gesagt wir werden zunächst einmal mit
den grünen sprechen bevor wir weitere
entscheidungen treffen nachdem das
gespräch mit den grünen gestern
stattgefunden hat stand heute die frage
der annahme des angebots der spd an und
wir haben entsprechend angenommen und
vereinbart am sonntag zu reden das ist
heute geschehen vielleicht vor zwei
stunden im laufe des vormittags ich kann
ihnen das jetzt wir haben jetzt noch
zwei fragen und dann würde ich die
fragerunde auch beenden einmal her
wüllenweber nochmal bitte ich alle oder
nachdem alle sich mit allen freundlich
unterhalten haben und womöglich selbst
geschossen haben wäre es denkbar dass
parallel sondiert würde dass man sagt
okay wir wollen eigentlich mit also
grüne und fdp wir wollen eigentlich mit
beiden partnern reden und um keine
präferenzen oder ihre präferenz ist ja
klar die der grünen womöglich auch um
das dann irgendwie aufzufangen sondiert
man im prinzip gleichzeitig und dann
abzuwägen wo es dann am ende besser
passt um den koalitionsverhandlungen an
zustande
wir werden diese fragen nicht jetzt
beantworten können weil wir zunächst
diese gespräche führen müssen die
ergebnisse dieser gespräche sind die
wichtigste voraussetzung um den nächsten
schritt gehen zu können deswegen war es
uns auch wichtig dass wir möglichst über
das wochenende mit allen bilateral
gesprochen haben die als mögliche
regierungspartner für uns in betracht
kommen und diese dinge laufen jetzt und
im zweiten schritt werden wir dann zu
einem hoffentlich klaren ergebnis kommen
das kann ich ihnen aber heute nicht
sagen weil wir uns an unseren inhalten
orientieren und jetzt stellt sich die
frage
gibt es einverständnis der möglichen
gesprächspartner für unsere inhaltlichen
positionen wie weit geht dieses
verständnis und gibt es das halte ich
für eine ganz zentrale frage einen
willen zur zusammenarbeit es gibt
natürlich immer eine interesse an den
stimmen des jeweils anderen aber es muss
einen willen auch zur zusammenarbeit
geben denn eine regierung die das land
nach vorne bringen will die muss nicht
nur handlungsfähig sein bezüglich der
fragen die am ende in einen möglichen
koalitionsvertrag stehen sondern auch
bezüglich der herausforderungen die im
laufe der legislaturperiode auf der
regierung zu kommen kann von denen man
heute gar nicht weiß dass sie bekommen
werden und das ist der entscheidende
schritt den man vorweg
erklären muss und diese klärende
gespräche sind das worüber ich ihnen
hier berichten kann wir kommen zur
letzten frage herr schuld bitte
wir sind sie haben gesagt es geht nach
innerhalb nur nach dem willen des der
partner spielt die stabilität des
partners der den kanzler stellen will
gar keine rolle das hängt sicherlich
auch eng miteinander zusammen wir
sprechen deswegen ja auch nicht nur mit
einzelnen personen sondern mit parteien
dann danke ich ihnen fürs kommen
wünschen noch einen schönen tag auf
wiedersehen vielen dank